sous la pression de l'opinion du monde
économique et des régions l'allemagne va
accélérer son déconfinement un projet
d'accord entre ans qu'elle a merkel et
les présidents de région devrait être
formellement adopté aujourd'hui le texte
lève la quasi-totalité des restrictions
dans le pays les précisions à délais
budget
le projet d'accord prévoit tout d'abord
la réouverture de toutes les écoles y
compris primaire à partir de la semaine
prochaine
toutes les écoles mais aussi les jardins
d'enfants certaines conditions tout de
même il faut pouvoir garantir les
mesures d'hygiène et de distanciation
social dans le secondaire l'allemagne
avait déjà autorisé la réouverture
enfin pour les universités le
gouvernement laisse aux différents états
régionaux le soin de décider
autre restriction appelé à sauter celles
imposées au magasin toutes les boutiques
pourront reprendre leurs activités ces
prochains jours
elle les propriétaires devront bien sûr
respecter des conditions d'hygiène et
contrôler les entrées pour éviter les
files d'attentes en revanche pour la
réouverture des restaurants cafés bars
et hôtels
le document laisse le champ libre aux 16
régions allemandes
les ministres régionaux de l'économie se
sont d'ailleurs mis d'accord pour
autoriser la reprise du secteur de la
gastronomie
dès samedi sur le plan culturel l'accord
prévoit également de laisser aux régions
la décision finale d'ouvrir au nom les
théâtres les salles de concert les clubs
ou encore les discothèques
côté sport les amateurs de football
seront bientôt comblé selon les médias
allemands les matchs en première et
deuxième division pourrait reprendre dès
le 21 mai mais à huis clos
le projet d'accord précise bien que
cette reprise des compétitions devra
être précédée d'une quarantaine de deux
semaines pour les équipes
la ligue allemande de football plaide
depuis longtemps pour cette reprise
vital pour la survie économique d'un
secteur qui emploie en allemagne
cinquante six mille personnes
enfin des mesures de confinement sont
prévues en cas de nouvelle vague de
coups
nation et laisser la décision des
cantons et des villes